Magnus put out a statement as we speak
yesterday saying dear Chess World at the
2022 singfield cup I made the
unprecedented professional decision to
withdraw from the tournament after my
round three game against Hans Neiman
a week later during the Champions chess
tour I resigned against Hans Neiman
after playing only one move I know that
my actions have frustrated many in the
chess Community I'm frustrated I want to
play chess I want to continue to play
Chess at the highest level in the best
events I believe that cheating in chess
is a big deal and an existential threat
to the game I also believe that chess
organizers and all those who care about
the sanctity of the game we love should
seriously consider increasing security
measures and methods of cheat detection
for over-the-board chess when Neiman was
invited last minute to the 2022
singfield cup I strongly considered
withdrawing prior to the event I
ultimately chose to play that's the
thing you're referring to is that he can
like now we know he was torn about the
whole thing I believe that Neiman has
cheated more and more recently than he
has publicly admitted
his over-the-board progress has been
unusual and throughout our game in
singfield cup I had the impression that
he wasn't tense or even fully
concentrating on the game in critical
positions while outplaying me as black
in a way I think only a handful of
players can do this game contributed to
changing my perspective
he must do we must do something about
cheating and for my part going forward I
don't want to play against people that
have cheated repeatedly in the past
because I don't know what they're
capable of doing in the future there's
more than I would like to say
unfortunately at this time I'm limited
in what I can say without explicit
permission from Neiman to speak openly
so
far I've only been able to speak with my
actions and those actions have stated
clearly that I am not willing to play
chess with Neiman I hope that the truth
in this matter comes out whatever it may
be sincerely Magnus Carlson
World Jazz Champion
um I was useful enough your statements
if I was a world yet no just say
whatever Lex Friedman what would be the
title yeah I don't know I think I would
not
even if I was a world champion I'd just
say Lex
or make up a title
and I feel like I really [ __ ] up in
life if I have to tweet a statement as
an image
that's like when you get
you've you're a politician and you got
caught cheating on your wife
like for many years in a row yes then I
tweet an image I'm sorry for all the
people I have hurt and the people that
believed in me
and what whatever else and then I would
sign World chess champion you know the
most like the the modern way to give a
statement what I thought Magnus was
going to do yeah I thought he was gonna
write
on the recent
Scandal or my statement on the past few
weeks twit longer
what do you mean so you put a URL oh
yeah so that's for tweets but it's
unlimited characters it's not a hundred
I didn't know what that is can you
explain that to me yeah so generally
when a celebrity has a giant audience on
Twitter they will make their statement
on social media and say what it is in a
sentence yeah one line and then there's
a link where's the link take you it's a
website called twit longer
twit longer yeah and that is where they
write their statements that is what I
was expecting I did this I haven't seen
this before oh this this is I don't have
one off the top of my head but it's just
that Kanye Kim Kardashian breaking up
that would use that streamers musicians
yeah I don't think politicians use it
because that it's just feeling yeah they
use the image you use my yeah Myspace
and Facebook right uh yeah
I'll probably go to I I like um
I mean I'm not just being biased here
just because I have a podcast I'm a huge
fan of podcasts I feel like I would go
on a podcast to talk about it with
somebody I trust so like long form and
discuss it